I'm back again.
This time with a really small segment.
We need to plug two histograms.
So first we need the values for
two stocks.
We get data for two stocks,
which is SPY and XOM.
We also go ahead and compute daily
returns for each of the stock.
Note that our daily return data frame
will have daily return values for
each of the stock prices.
Now like before, we just call histogram
function on the daily return data frame,
and let's see what happens.
We keep the bins count to be 20.
Now let's run this.
Okay, so we got two subplots.
But we go ahead one step and
plot them on the same x and
y axis so that we can compare
the histogram of SPY and XOM.
To get two histograms on the same x and
y axis, we call the histogram
functions separately on each of
the stocks daily return values.
We also add the label parameter so
that we can differentiate between
the histogram of the SPY and XOM.
Now, let's run this.
Here we go.
We get two histogram of SPY and
XOM on the same X and Y axis.
Now you can compare the histogram and
see that the teams of XOM is
thin as compared to the SPY.
That's it for this coding segment.
I'll be back soon.
Over to you professor.